digamos que nos dan esta reacción y nos
piden encontrar el potencial estándar de
celda podemos hacer eso usando nuestros
potenciales estándar de reducción si
desde esta primera media reacción si
vemos el ión de plata se añades un
electrón a lyon de plata obtienes plata
metálica ganancia de electrones
reducción así que esta es una media
reacción de reducción si vemos la
reacción en la derecha podemos ver que
estamos reduciendo el ión de plata aquí
está tu guión de plata que está siendo
reducido a plata metálica necesitamos
esta media reacción como está escrita
esto será nuestra media reacción de
reducción
entonces tenemos a que más tenemos a
gemas más un electrón
dándonos plata metálica aquí
el potencial estándar de reducción para
esta media reacción es de 0.8 volts
esto es 0.8 volts luego veamos qué más
está sucediendo convertimos zinc
metálico a iones zinc 2 más como
convierte zinc metálico a 52 más el
simple metálico necesitará perder 2
electrones para convertirse en 5 2 más
pérdida de electrones es oxidación
shibasaki a esta media reacción podemos
ver que esta media reacción está escrita
como media reacción de reducción 52 más
está siendo reducido gana 2 electrones
para transformarse en zinc metálico
tenemos que escribir esto como una media
reacción de oxidación
nos lavan como una reducción y
necesitamos escribirla como una media
reacción de oxidación simplemente
necesitamos revertir la tenemos que
empezar con 5 metálico empezamos con
zinc metálico aquí
y para convertir el zinc metálico
en iones de 52 más
tenemos que perder 2 electrones
pérdida de electrones es oxidación
tenemos que encontrar el potencial
estándar de oxidación después y podemos
hacer eso viendo nuestra tabla otra vez
el potencial estándar de reducción para
esta media reacción como está escrito es
menos 0.76 volts ya que revertimos esta
media reacción revertimos esta media
reacción necesitamos cambiar el signo de
negativo a positivo para el potencial de
reducción es menos 0.76 para el
potencial de oxidación es mas 0.76 el
potencial estándar de oxidación para
esta media reacción es mas 0.76 volts
ahora tenemos que tomar en cuenta los
moles si vemos nuestra reacción tenemos
dos moles de iones de plata siendo
reducidos a dos moles de plata metálica
aquí abajo tenemos
mol de iones de plata siendo reducido a
un molde plata metálica necesitamos
multiplicar todo por dos aquí obtenemos
dos moles de iones de plata los cuales
requieren dos moles de electrones para
transformarse en dos moles de plata
metálica ahora podría ser muy tentador
decir
y entonces solo multiplicamos nuestro
potencial de reducción por 2 también
pero no lo hacemos por la razón de la
que hablamos en el vídeo anterior el
voltaje es una propiedad intensiva así
que no importa si estás formando un
molde plata o dos moles de plata el
voltaje es el mismo así que vamos a
dejar el voltaje en 0.8 volts ahora
tenemos el número de electrones al que
es igual por lo que podemos sumar
nuestras dos medias reacciones para
obtener nuestra reacción total
si sumas la media reacción de reducción
y la media reacción de oxidación juntas
obtenemos nuestra reacción total los
electrones perdidos por el zinc estos
dos electrones de aquí son los mismos
electrones que ganan los iones de plata
eso se cancela y en el lado izquierdo
tendríamos 2 ag más zinc metálico
escribamos eso aquí 2 ag
más más zinc metálico
y para nuestros productos aquí a la
derecha tenemos 2 ag más si dos más
tenemos 2 ag más 5
2 más
nota que esta es nuestra reacción si en
marco esto de aquí
esta reacción total que acabamos de
encontrar
es lo mismo que lo que nos dieron en
nuestro problema así que encontramos
nuestra reacción total pero recuerda
quieren que encontremos el potencial
estándar de celda como encontramos un
potencial estándar de celda hablamos de
cómo hacer esto en un vídeo anterior
encontramos el potencial estándar de
celda
puedes pensar en cómo encontramos la
reacción total
sumamos la media reacción de reducción y
la media reacción de oxidación para
obtener la reacción total para encontrar
el potencial estándar de celda
necesitamos sumar el potencial estándar
de reducción y el potencial estándar de
oxidación si sumamos el potencial
estándar de reducción
y el potencial estándar de oxidación
deberíamos obtener el potencial estándar
para la celda continuamos haciendo eso
el potencial estándar de celda es igual
a esto será 0.8 volts positivos
0.08 volts positivos más 0.76 volts
positivos más 0.76 volts positivos lo
que es igual a 1.56 volts positivos el
potencial estándar de celda
1.56 volts positivos
recuerda que un valor positivo para un
potencial significa una reacción
espontánea esto es cómo utilizar tus
potenciales de reducción para obtener un
potencial estándar de celda